good morning John it's one of those
Fridays again on which I make videos and
today I'm gonna making a video unlike
any other I've ever made on vlogbrothers
it's a video that contains no cuts I'm
just going to talk and I'm gonna talk to
you for four minutes and then it's gonna
be over everything's gonna stay in
confessional style how do you decide
what to do with any given moment it's a
big important question that maybe we
don't ask ourselves all the time I have
had a system for the last 10 years
that's worked pretty well and that has
basically been do whatever you want
that's far like it's more like do
whatever needs doing right like I feel
very compelled by my obligations and I
have two main sources of obligations I
want to talk about so there's there's
one that's like this is a thing that I
can do that not a lot of other people
could do or pull off and it would be
good and like I just want it to exist
and the obligation it's almost to the
idea itself or to the universe itself
just to make this thing exist and I like
that's what pushes me to make new stuff
like like create art but also like make
scishow or crash course or like we
recently relaunched how to adult because
I just think that that's the thing that
should exist in the world and we made a
podcast
HFS holy freaking science which is like
an adult language podcast where we get
really excited like too excited about
science and hang out hanging out with
friends it's really fun and like those
are things that I feel like that these
are great they should exist I could help
them exist in a way that other people
may not be able to because I have tools
that other people don't have access to
and then there's like the obligation to
the existing ideas kind of like this is
less exciting but it's um it's more it's
there's more it's more compelling
because there are people relying on it
there are people who love the thing and
wanted to keep existing I have a
obligation to like the attendees at
VidCon I have an obligation to all the
creators to come to VidCon I have an
obligation to nerdfighteria to you John
and like these aren't things that I
resent like they are pushed me to make
things and make them
and I need that and like we just
launched wizard school like wizard
schools the game now it exists people
are playing it they like it but there's
a bunch of Kickstarter perks that we
haven't sent out yet and I feel terrible
about it I'm sorry if you're one of
those people like those obligations I
need to push me to do stuff but also two
things happened at the same time this
year after ten years I really does feel
this way that changed this strategy for
me like out like at the same time
weirdly the election happened which made
me think like there are a lot of things
that need protecting and that I might
not be doing a good job of of like
making the world better in in the best
ways I can and maybe I should have been
thinking about that before the election
I definitely should have but like now I
feel I feel like it is more pressing
than ever and and that has changed sort
of like what I'm thinking about like
like how I've prioritized things and
then there's a baby and like like but
like that at any given moment he is
always for the rest of my life my child
is going to be my prime obligation and
that's a new thing for me and as I get
any given moment it's like hey Dad what
are you doing and I'm like I got a stuff
to do and he's like but me I got cheeks
that I'm like you're right impenetrable
argument child so that's it's the
situation I'm in and basically what it
means that that like the systems that I
used to use aren't necessarily the best
systems for my current life and that's
okay I just have to create new systems
and that is a little bit difficult and
painful sometimes but figuring it out
and it's 100% worth it
John I'll see you on Tuesday